you were at however dwindle on Facebook
at Harvard Mark Zuckerberg I went to
college undergrad with me I was hissing
classmate and so Facebook definitely
existed before I was starting wearing
best but I you know 2007-2008 when I was
starting the idea Facebook I think was
founded in like 2004 so he said but it
was very much you know you weren't
building your business on you were at
Harvard when he launched Facebook at
Harvard remember when you heard about
Facebook uh do we remember are you
kidding you liked could never have
forgotten
um yeah I remember at actually at the
end of your username what would be the
number of Facebook user you were and I
was like in the hundreds so I was like
roughly around 150 uh and you knew it
because it was just the most helpful
thing on the planet it's like oh what's
that person's name again I can look them
up um and I was joked with my husband
when my husband asked me out I like
couldn't look up who he was yet he'd
asked me out before Facebook existed and
I remember being like how I can't
remember who he is like is it this guy
or that guy and it just like my kids
will never know a world where you like
can't look somebody up I mean it's gonna
be a big deal or were you like this is
useful for Harvard and yeah I mean like
could you foresee that it was gonna be
like a seventy-five billion dollar
company um you know I can't take credit
for having like something that was that
kind of crystal ball ish but you knew it
was a big deal um really quickly you
could just tell it was like the amount
of time you were spending on it how
quickly was spreading at when it went to
other colleges and you could look up
you're at those schools when you could
poke people I mean it was you know to
the credit of market was an incredibly
infectious did you know him personally I
know so I did know many we are an
undergrad I met him a handful of times
and I know his family and his siblings
pretty well at but know when he was
starting
by joining when it was it's like hey
this thing is kind of taking off I'm
extra now Harvard you were thinking
about drop you know you dropped out of
business school anyways to start a
business I actually was thinking at that
time of dropping out of Harvard to start
learn that's basically so my mom
convinced me to graduate I said to her I
want to go start a company I know I need
to my mom was like can you just graduate
pretty please I've gotten into Harvard
Business School my mom was like huge at
least graduate from from college and
took my mom's credit I did I'm glad I
did but I that that itch to go start
something was like pretty alive and I
you know to the credit of like a Mark
Zuckerberg when you are so close to
seeing businesses get built you know I
think they called it the Facebook effect
which is when you can see how powerful
the internet can be and if you're a you
a hardworking person who has skills
you're like huh maybe I should go do
something and but I so so yes and I will
definitely say I think Facebook's
spawned an entire you know
you
[Music]